1286 and scotland is in crisis this
crisis with the result of the untimely
death of King Alexander the third who
had no direct male heirs this crisis
brought to the forefront of Scottish
politics the problems surrounding
Scotland's position relative to England
since 1066 Scottish Kings had regularly
pledged their loyalty and had sometimes
outright submitted to the kings of
England to the kings of England this
meant that Scotland could not appoint a
new king without their say-so and
importantly a new king would have to
recognise the superiority of the English
monarch both the kings of England and
the kings of Scotland held lands in each
other's kingdoms English owned lands in
Scotland was subject to English law
whereas the Scottish owned lands in
England were also subject to English law
so before he died Alexander the third
had his granddaughter Margaret the
daughter of the King of Norway
acknowledged as his there Margaret was
only three at this time and so the
governance of Scotland fell to a group
of six men known as the guardians until
she was old enough to make the journey
back they had several responsibilities
the first was to govern the second was
to appoint a regent to rule in
Margaret's name until she was of age the
third was to find her husband the
Guardians approached it with the first
of England to arrange a marriage between
Mark Orton Edwards eldest son Edward the
arrangements were finalized in the 1290
Treaty of Bergen which stipulated that
the kingdoms of Scotland and England
would remain entirely separate and the
ingham was not Scotland superior
remember that any children of the
marriage between Edward and Margaret
would inherit both England and Scotland
which had the potential for political
union this concerned the Scottish who
weren't particularly keen on the idea of
being Wales the worries around future
offspring became moot after Margaret
died later in 1290 this had the effect
of plunging Scotland into another
succession crisis which are two major
claimants the first was John Balliol and
the second was Robert Bruce the process
of choosing a new king is often referred
to as the great Corps since it was kind
of important there were worries about
the potential for civil war and so
Edward the first was invited to
adjudicate and select one of the two as
the next king of Scots he did so on the
condition that the claimants acknowledge
him as their rightful Lord which they
did in 1292 Edward sided with John
Bailey oh so King John's reign was
overshadowed by Edward who often
asserted his own authority over Scotland
as its rightful lord one way he did this
was to give English courts jurisdiction
over Scotland he also demanded that
Scotland as his vassal had to provide
men and money for the war with France
the war had started because Philippe
therefore for France had declared
Edward's possessions in France were
forfeit and war with France was
expensive hence why the Scottish wanted
no part of it the continued humiliations
by Edward were too
for John's Lords to bear and so in 1295
they took over governing the Roman
appointed 12 men as its Guardians one of
the first acts by this Council of
Guardians was to sign a treaty of
alliance with France in the same year
the next J King John renounce his homage
to Edward which was to put it lightly
upsetting to him to Edward this was
nothing short of treason and so invasion
the English and Scottish armies clashed
at Dunbar which was an overwhelming
English victory in the wake of Dunbar
the Scottish army collapsed and was
scattered and many prominent Scottish
Nobles were imprisoned Edward then took
several castles the most notable being
Edinburgh which held out for only five
days within five months of the first
English troops crossing the border King
John Balliol had abdicated soon after
this the Stone of Destiny an important
part of the coronation ceremony and a
symbol of Scottish independence was
taken to England by Edward Bailey Oh was
locked up in the Tower of London and
Edward took over the running of Scotland
John de Warenne was appointed as the
guardian of Scotland and Hugh decreasing
him was appointed as its treasurer in
1297 most of the Scottish nobility
submitted to wet wooden pledged their
fealty not all Scots were willing to do
this and resistance to English rule
began to pick up in the second half of
1297 in the north where English
authority was weaker the resistance was
led by Andrew Moray whereas in central
Scotland it was led by William Wallace
these two joined forces and launched
numerous raids against English held
towns and the Scottish regained control
of important cities and castles they
eventually cleared the English out of
all of the north barring Dundee which
they then laid siege to it would toss
war em was relieving the siege who
assembled an army march north in order
to get to Dundee this army needed to
cross the river forth and chose to do so
here at Stirling it was here the English
army met the Scottish one at the Battle
of Stirling Bridge was crossing the
bridge the English including Hugh
decreasing him were slaughtered whereas
the Scottish only suffered minor
casualties which happened to include
Andrew Moray
were in retreated and as a result the
English had basically abandoned Scotland
this left William Wallace is the primary
leader of the Scottish resistance he
started to reach out to foreign kingdoms
to re-establish diplomatic and trade
links and he also began to administrate
the areas of Scotland which were under
his control
Wallace began raiding across the border
and following the retreating English the
Scottish burned hundreds of villages
before they themselves turned back to
Scotland
Wallace was appointed as the guardian of
Scotland and began to prepare for
Edwards inevitable retaliation Edward
was at this point fighting in France and
after making peace with the French he
returned to York and in mid 1298 he and
his army crossed into Scotland the
English and Scottish clashed at the
Battle of Falkirk which the English won
handily mostly due to Edward's use of
longbowman Wallace was forced to retreat
and his reputation was in ruins he was
replaced as the guardian of Scotland by
two men the first being a man called
Robert the Bruce and the second being
John Comyn the two hated each other and
it wasn't long before Robert the Bruce
resigned
fortunately Wallace's early diplomatic
efforts have paid off particularly those
with France in the papacy the French
came to custody of John Balliol and the
Pope ordered Edward to halt his advance
which Edward promptly ignored fighting
continued intermittently over the coming
years and it was during this in 1302
when Robert the Bruce pledged his
loyalty to Edward in 1304 Edward struck
a decisive blow and the Scottish
nobility submitted again William Wallace
did not submit however and he continued
to harass the English this harassment
continued until 1305 when he was
captured just outside of Glasgow taken
back to England given a show trial and
executed shortly afterwards Edward
issued the ordinance for the government
of Scotland which gave Scottish Lords
some autonomy but Scotland was legally
considered a conquered territory during
the peace Robert the Bruce or an
opportunity for himself
the Scottish King was gone and Bruce was
a relative of the previous king
Alexander the third meaning he had a
claim only one other man could contest
the throne and that was John Comyn and
Robert found a subtle and clever way of
getting around Commons claim he murdered
him Robert made the mistake of murdering
him in a church which the Pope did not
like and so excommunication a month
after Commons death Robert the Bruce was
crowned King Robert many of the Scottish
nobility weren't happy with this and
after some fighting Robert fled into
exile in 1307 Edward the first died and
was succeeded by his son Edward the
second unlike his father Edward the
second was not exactly the martial type
and did little to challenge Robert
Robert now had a free hand in Scotland
my 1308 he was in control of this
territory in by 1309 the Scottish Nobles
had been brought to heel being much more
secure in his position Robert started to
concentrate in the running of his
kingdom and he established links with
France the papacy in Norway he held
Parliament as st. Andrews here but his
main focus was on war with England and
the recovery of the southern Scottish
lands so in 1310 King Edward ventured
north but this invasion came to nothing
primarily because Edward was on the
brink of civil war with his Lords
Edwards conflict with his Nobles lasted
until 1313 and during this time Robert
capitalized and retook all of these
lands he then demanded that the
remaining Scottish Nobles renounce their
homage to Edward and give it to him so
Edward was now unable to ignore the
Scottish threat and in 1314 he marched a
large army into Scotland the two
it's met here at Bannockburn in England
with its much larger and better-equipped
army seemed certain to win yet due to
immense tactical errors by the English
the Scottish were victorious in the
English army was scattered and retreated
after Bannockburn the vast majority of
Scottish territory was firmly under
Roberts control robert began to take the
fight to the English and invaded Roberts
brother Edward Bruce was ordered to
invade Ireland in 1315 in the hopes of
setting up his own Kingdom there
furthermore Edward was also made the
heir to the Scottish throne since Robert
didn't have any children the reason for
the invasion of Ireland was to cut off
Irish taxes to England and to open up a
second front which would cost the
English a lot more money long story
short I didn't go too well in in 1318
Edward was killed at the Battle of folk
art and with him died the idea of a
Scottish ruled Ireland Robert task men
like James Douglas with increasingly
ambitious raid into England and in 1318
he retook Berwick the war was fairly
quiet for the next two years barring the
Scottish victory at the Battle of
might'n in 1320 his clergyman and his
Nobles sent a declaration called the
Declaration of Arbroath to the Pope
this declaration stated that Scotland
was an independent kingdom that Robert
was its rightful king due to his actions
and the Edward the first and second were
unjust in any attempt to conquer
Scotland the papacy officially
considered Edward Bailey or the son of
the now dead King John to be the
rightful king of Scotland though in 1320
King Robert also uncovered a plot
against him by William two souls who was
likely working on behalf of Edward
Bailey Oh Robert had William brought
before him and he was tried found guilty
and spent the rest of his life locked up
in 1320 for the issue of the succession
was dealt with when Robert Sayre David
was born and two years later the
Scottish renewed their alliance with the
French with the Treaty of Corbeil 1327
saw a major upheaval in England which
greatly affected the Scottish Wars this
upheaval was the ousting of edward ii by
his wife Queen Isabella and her lover
Roger Mortimer Edward was forced to
abdicate the first English King to ever
do so and he was replaced with his son
Edward the third Edward was too young to
govern on his own and so the running of
the kingdom fell to Isabella and
Mortimer both Mortimer and Edward wanted
Scotland back under English domination
so in 1327 invasion this invasion went
terribly in the English were forced to
suit for peace this culminated in the
1328 Treaty of Edinburgh Northampton in
which both sides agreed that one
Scotland was independent and not under
English overlordship to Robert the Bruce
and his heirs were the rightful kings of
the Scots and three it set with the
border between England and Scotland as
being this ie the pre-war border meaning
everyone
for nothing in return for all of this
the English were to get a sack of cash
Edward also agreed to return the Stone
of Destiny but that took a bit longer
than expected by which I mean it wasn't
returned until 1996 so the English
nobility saw this treaty is completely
humiliating which is why ultimately the
peace between England and Scotland
wouldn't last there are many important
legacies to the first Scottish war of
independence two major ones were the
affirmation of a Scottish identity in
the establishment of the old alliance
which meant that any English war with
either France or Scotland would become a
war on two fronts which unsurprisingly
happens many times in the coming
centuries yet as far as England was
concerned it made it clear that the
English were not the uncontested Lords
of the British Isles and that the future
English Scottish relationship would
operate within the framework of war at
least for the next three centuries I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching there are some books in
the description if you'd like to learn
more
you